everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today are gonna be starting
our coverage of the Blitz championships
the past three days you've been going
over the rapid championships rapid being
15 minutes games for each player and
then they get 10 minutes per incremental
move magnus carlsen became the two-time
champion so the world champion with
regular chess time and then with the
rapid championship going for the
three-peat which would just be
phenomenal if he could somehow win blitz
as well but blitz being a three minutes
per opponents they also get two minutes
per incremental move so very very fast
chess even if you are gaming those two
seconds it can be very very taxing on
all the players and as you'll see
there's usually a lot of mistakes
there's just not enough time to find the
exact precise move you should make so a
lot of moves that sometimes make you
scratch your head you got to keep in
mind that they just don't have a lot of
time and many of the moves especially as
you get past and move let's say 20 or 30
they only have 10 seconds left on their
clock and so they're just moving very
very rapid the first game we're gonna be
going over today is udit poly gar whole
garyun grandmaster she's a phenomenal
player sister of Susan Polgar who is uh
very very respected in the United States
and her opponents going to be a very
young chess player but a grandmaster
front from China yang EU he is just 20
years old but a phenomenal chess player
both of these players have played an
extremely good blitz tournament so far
so I thought it'd be good to actually
watch them and see how they play in a
fast chess setting unit starts out with
pawn to e4 now we see this Sicilian
defense from you Knight f3 so basic
Sicilian defense here after the take we
do see a variation we don't see super
often and that is the conversation with
pawn to a6 Bishop to d3 simple
development moves from both sides Queen
to c7 pawn to c4 pushing forward with
pawn here to d6 Knight c3 Bishop e7
getting ranked to castle on the King
side Bishop to e3 pawn to b6 again all
these moves that were going over the
both sides have
abilities of doing different things so
in this case you know you could castle
on the kingside first he could play
Knight to d7 so that there's no
incorrect moves especially early on and
a blitz style formats usually just want
to develop your pieces try to control
the set of the board not give up too
much time because you know that going
into the middle game and the endgame
you're gonna need to do a lot of
thinking so usually you don't see any
crazy lines early on into the game it's
going to be just very very simple
development so pawn to b6 route to a c1
again very basic stuff rooks controlling
the long files that's usually where you
want to put your rooks
Bishop to b7 both sides going to try to
control the long file or diagonals with
their bishops pawn to b4 very aggressive
move you know both sides definitely want
to have a win coming out of this they're
kind of at that point in the tournament
where they can actually see pretty high
and if you're not familiar with kind of
the format it's you play a match and
then the top players they play and then
whoever's the top two they're playing
each other and so you're kind of always
moving to the top you're not just seated
with random players on the board so
these players really trying to move
their way up in this format we see
castling on the kingside palm pushing
forward to f5 and this is probably the
the first interesting part in this
particular match because you plays it an
interesting move probably somewhat of a
mistake if you kind of run it through
chess engines that they kind of give a
head-scratcher
he plays Queen here to see a twitch it
very quickly looks like it's okay you
want to add another defender to the
square here on a6 because White has the
pawn here on F f5 it has the knight here
on D for both attacking but if the pawn
takes the Queen's not going to recapture
and if the pawn recaptures well the
night here on d4 it doesn't really
matter too much this is kind of a hay
poison pawn right here where it's gonna
have to be you know defended for a good
part of the game it also opens up a
little bit of weakness on this King side
for black so the queen of c8 although it
is trying to protect this square it
isn't doing too much
1 another option that black would have
is to play pawn to e5 and not even
worrying about this but solidifying sort
of that Center control of the board so
kind of as we'd alluded to you decides
to play that Queen to c8 we see the
capture and then pawn to b4 you did not
even worried about taking this pawn on
e6 she's gonna worry about that later in
the game she did also have a few
different options could have played
Knight here to a4 attacking this pawn on
b6 I was trying to find the small
weaknesses your opponents have b6
definitely one of those east six one of
those so both of these squares she could
kind of attack because her opponents
kind of forced to try to defend that you
know Knight taking here on b6 forking
both this rook and this Queen here on c8
could potentially come back here play
Bishop to d8 you always want to have
your opponent in a defensive position
you could now see pawn pushing for to c5
after the take here pawn to b4 that the
pawn can't take with that the knight the
Queen would fall right here so that this
is one option the the you that had in
the particular game she played pawn to
b4 which again as you're playing over
the board just pushing forward with your
pawns it is never really a bad thing we
now see a knight to c6 you definitely
needs to get some counter play get some
of his other pieces involved into the
game you decides to go ahead and take
pawn to b5 pushing further Queen comes
back a little bit now the Knight to a4
move sometimes players though they'll
play and then their opponent has a few
seconds to think and so that actually
gives them time to think about some of
the move so she did eventually find that
the Knight to a4 move Knight down here
to e4 taking which which again is one of
those interesting moves that it you know
if you kind of do a lot of analysis or
run it through an engine probably not
the strongest move on board could have
come back here to d7 definitely has a
lot of room to breathe in this
particular case doesn't have to commit
to too much can kind of play defense for
awhile but taking the pawn here on e4
opens up some complications with Queen 2
for this attacks the square here on e6
which starts to attack the king it's
also attacking the knight right here so
now Youth has both her bishop and her
queen attacking the nights here on e4
where his opponents or her opponents has
just the bishop here on b7 so again some
complications that yous gonna have to do
with pawn take now the Queen comes in
not worrying about this right away Bonin
has to move now there's gonna be an
exchange and now this pawn can take and
the knight doesn't have to worry too
much because this rook has swung over
here to f8 the knight comes back you did
the sides that's completely okay with
her she's going to take back and said we
look at both sides what they're planning
to do Black's gonna need to get a little
bit more aggressive with his bishops his
bishops back here on the seventh rank
are not nearly as potent as you this
here are on the third rank this pawn
here on c5 past pawns to a blacks gonna
look to try to push forward with that
definitely needs to find some way to you
know keep off an attack from White's we
do have the bishop here on d3 attacking
this square here on h7 which is a huge
weakness something that you can
definitely try to attack right here you
know we do see the bishop here on a b7
attacking this square maybe giving this
other Bishop involved into the game
attacking the square here on h2 might
make a lot of sense
but the Queen here on c7 is pretty
passive the Queen here on e6 is very
aggressive so although if we kind of
look at it both sides have equal
material White has a much more
aggressive game and so use definitely
gonna have to find a way to dig deep
defend and potentially get a draw or if
you just slips up capture the win we now
see the Queen come back here to h3 lying
down on that square that we talked about
h7 which is now being attacked by both
units Bishop and her Queen right here
pawn to g6 trying to save a little bit
does open up the door for a bishop to
come into the game attack this King
right here the pawn wouldn't be able to
take because this rook is attacking this
Queen if the pawn moves so that's
something to keep in mind bishop taking
here on g6 opens up the door for Queen
taking here on h7 so black needs to find
her way to protect the the square in h7
the the really only way to do that is to
move this Bishop the the two moves that
make a lot of sense one would be Bishop
here to f6 it opens up the door for this
Queen to defend this grand age 7 and the
other one is Bishop here to d6
unfortunately for you he chose the wrong
option he chose Bishop here to these six
and the reason that is a problem is you
that in my opinion found the deflection
of the tournament by playing Bishop here
to d4 now if you if you study the game
and you have an hour and a half like I
did to go over every move you'll be able
to find this but in a game where she
only has twenty seconds left on the
clock for her to find this deflection
move I think is phenomenal and speaks to
to all the different things she can see
on board but this is so powerful it's
attacking the King right here the pawn
could not take because the rook can
swing up here and take here on c7 this
is also important because that Queen was
protecting this pawn and now it's going
to be an easy checkmates for y to come
on board so you can see this is
different than if the bishop came here
to f6 no longer can you display that
move right here now play could continue
with the work swing over here to d1 we
could see Bishop come back here to c8
white still it is up definitely more the
aggressor but black has more fighting
chances in this particular game so you
did decide after the bishop takes here
on g6 to come back here to d6 we see the
deflection of the tournament in my mind
King here to g8 queen coming involved
into the action a little bit more a
little bit more aggression we're coming
up taking now that King comes to f8 and
then we have checkmate here on EA so and
again we don't see checkmate that often
so it's always good to look at I do want
to go
another option if your if you're
watching this game and you're like you
know why wouldn't the Queen just take
here on f7 we'll kind of go over that
variation what that might look like so
the Queen could take here on d6 all of a
sudden whites up quite a bit material
could take this this Bishop here on a d4
has a passed pawn it's gonna be very
difficult to actually push that pass
pawn but now rook up here to c7
attacking the Queen also threatening
just Queen here to d8 that's gonna be
very very bad also attacking the bishop
here so after the Queen moves definitely
needs to move we could see rook here to
e7 continuing the pressure Queen to f8
Queen to e6 check and there's no way to
really stop everything white can easily
get a quick checkmate get the Queen or
move over get this Bishop here on b7 and
then just continue to easily win the
game so you decided to go ahead and take
the the honourable approach and just
play King to f8 and then give you to the
checkmate here on eh again also running
very very low on time so great
performance by you the poly gar both
players playing extremely well again in
this blitz tournament I really enjoy
this I think it's the closest we're
gonna get to watching grandmasters play
like normal people just because they do
make some mistakes but every now and
then that they will show a glimpse of
brilliance so far as you know finding a
great decoy move or deflection but but
understanding the basics of finding
outpost controlling the center pushing
past pawns you know getting your rooks
to the open files controlling the long
diagonals with your Bishop so all these
different things you can really see in
this game because they're not even
thinking about it so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this game watching some some
blitz matches some some of the
phenomenal players are going on so we'll
try to cover as many matches as possible
but hopefully you'll learn something
enjoy and I'll see you guys in the next
video thanks for watching